here now with reaction Fox News
contributor former Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo uh I have a lot of questions
for you tonight Mr secretary please be
patient with us let's let's first get
your reaction to the release of these
two American hostages um in principle I
am against Ransom payments for hostages
I really am because I think it will
result in more hostage taking um however
uh Joe Biden did make that offer to Iran
and I think that worked out Terri and I
thought it was a bad idea uh however I
think Israel might have some negotiating
room not necessarily a ransom payment
but they could turn the water back on
and the lights back on and services back
on if they released uh if they released
host hostages would that be an area you
might
support well Sean to listen to that man
talk about his family coming home is
just Joy it is love uh it was wonderful
to hear uh sitting here just brought me
brought me to tears um it's been a long
two weeks for uh all of the families
that have been held hostage and those
who lost loved ones on October 7th you
know as for the decision about when
Israel will go in I think that's their
decision to make and I've begun to hear
a lot of Americans talking about well
this would this would be something we
should discourage the Israelis for doing
and Sean this is very necessary if we're
going to prevent there from being
another 10 American hostages and then
another 10 American hostages you're
going to have to take out Hamas jot and
TI and then the United States is going
to have to go after the primary actor
which is the Islamic Republic of Iran
last night President Biden said in his
speech he says we're going to continue
to hold Iran accountable I mean it it
would be laughable if it wasn't so darn
dangerous Sean dangerous for every one
of us every dangerous for every American
danger for every Israeli danger for the
Saudis the amadis the kuwaitis everybody
in the region this is the world's
largest state sponsor of Terror they
killed 30 Americans on October 7th and
they raped grandmas they killed babies
and this cannot be the case that the
defeat of Hamas stops what happened it
has to be the case that Iran is held
accountable we have the capacity to do
that and President Biden has the
responsibility if he's going to deter
further aggression and more American
hostages being taken it is not going to
be by writing them big checks and making
them wealthy it is going to be by
imposing real costs on them and we know
how to do
it I I think you will agree with me Mr
secretary that the goal has to be that
Gaza can no longer be a launch zone for
what has over the years now been tens
and tens and tens of thousands of
rockets fired into neighboring Israeli
cities I have been there I have seen the
the damage the city of stote has
literally had 10,000 rockets by the time
I went there a number of years ago fired
into that one city in 10 years 10,000
rockets that only takes 13 seconds from
the minute it's fired to land which is
why kids play in underground bunker
playgrounds so it doesn't want to of
their major objectives have to be to
prevent that from ever becoming a
launching pad
again it's their Duty it's the Israeli
government's duty to prevent that from
happening again I heard you say Sean
that you had been in those tunnels they
need to eliminate the tunnels as well
and then prevent them from being rebuilt
it's now pretty clear when the Israelis
pulled out in 2006 Hamas had absolutely
no intention of making life better for
anyone living in that place they had the
singular intention of continuing to
build out along with their Islamic
Republic Patron build out a system that
could wipe Jews from wipe Jews out of
Israel that can't be permitted to happen
Israel is going to have to take this
down and then the harder task of making
sure it's not rebuilt if we had those
kind of missiles Landing in the United
States from foreign soil I promise you
the president of United States would
have the responsibility to prevent it
from ever happening again and we would
take that no matter what any other
country told us what many may forget is
your prior role prior to you becoming
Secretary of State you were the you were
the head of of the CIA uh you do know a
thing or two about intelligence I'd
never been to Langley except I came once
to have a meeting with you uh and uh it
was actually very eye openening I felt
like I was in a real Jason bour movie uh
but on a serious note when the media in
this country and worldwide and I'm
talking about all the media ABC NBC CBS
msdnc CNN fake news uh the New York
Times The Washington Post when they all
came out quoting Hamas propagandists
saying that Israel was responsible for
the attack on this hospital and they
killed 500 people meanwhile it didn't
even hit the hospital it hit a parking
lot and took out a couple of cars but
that went worldwide and as a result
Israel was put in the horrific position
of having to defend itself and prove to
the world that it was not true and in
doing so they had to reveal their
intelligence methods and cap
capabilities uh to the entire world
obviously the terrorists that they had
on tape likely didn't know they were
being taped and now that uh the world
knows this they gave up a very important
piece of the National Security and I
think I can't even calculate the damage
that the media did to Israel in this
your
thoughts yeah it's very real Sean uh
look they should be ashamed of
themselves but we we know that that's
seldom the case with the New York Times
and The Washington Post we saw what they
did talking about the the laptop we saw
what they did talking about the Russian
HOA Russian hoax narrative they never
even bother to correct themselves they
just collect their prizes their po of
prizes and move on with their lives in
this case they did two terrible things
in this case by buying a storyline from
Hamas I mean think about that Sean
buying a storyline from Hamas they put
have blood on their hands there were
people injured there were riots our
embassies were under assault and second
um they haven't even fixed it yet and
now Israel's had to go out and share
both a set of information and some tools
that they had which will change how
Israel's able to collect to save further
Israeli lives and frankly American lives
too it was Reckless it was certainly
dangerous and I hope that every one of
them will go out and say we got it wrong
we apologize it was our fault and then
put processes in place from pres
preventing this kind of misinformation
from being foisted around the world when
they had no reason to believe there was
any evidence that this was an Israeli
weapon system that actually hit a had
executed a strike inside of
Gaza okay let's assume this becomes Mr
secretary a two-front war let's assume
that they are battling Hezbollah uh in
the north and they are battling Gaza in
the South uh also we have to add this
fact and that is the Iranians are saying
your time is up they have threatened
their own involvement in this conflict
now if I may add to all of that uh we
have Iranian rockets and drones have
targeted US troops in Iran and Syria so
so Iran is involved in the plotting
planning and scheming they're providing
the Weaponry they're fighting proxy war
after proxy war now they're threatening
direct involvement and they are directly
involved in the attacks against
Americans what should the US role under
President Biden be what should that
Doctrine be based on what we know they
are responsible for right now he doesn't
seem to want to talk about Iran very
much Sean first the the fantasy of a p
needs to be disabused from anyone
working in the United States government
that they need to that the idea that
somehow you're going to appease your way
out of this conflict is pure faler all
and it resulted in 30 dead Americans and
now still almost a dozen Americans being
held and so real simple um first you
would go reimpose the economic sanctions
you would impose a price an economic
price on the Islamic Republic of Iran
second if you just go back at the
proxies if you just take out the the the
Knuckleheads who have been paid to go
kill
if if if that's all you do and the
Ayatollah and president RI sit in tan
they they'll be laughing uh that is they
will kill Americans with their proxies
and the Americans will simply kill their
proxies we can't let that be the case uh
you talked about my time at CIA we have
many tools Sean with which to respond to
this there's a wide range of options
that can be presented to the president
of the United States to make very clear
to the Ayatollah that you can't continue
what you have been doing instead of
giving them $6 billion through hostages
we should have told them if you don't
give those hostages back we will begin
to impose costs that's the way we got
hostages back without paying a nickel
for them it works we can protect America
we can restore deterrence but we have to
be clear that appeasing Iran will never
get us to that place where we can be
safe secure and the Middle East can be
safe and secure and prosperous as well
how damaging has the Biden policy on
energy Ben to rely on the lifeblood of
the world's economy on countries many of
whom don't particularly like us uh why
did Joe Biden and what are the
consequences of his decision to allow
Iran uh to once again be able to sell
their oil on the open markets uh can you
even explain to this audience in any
reasonable way the thinking behind
giving billions of dollars to the number
one state sponsor of Terror uh I have a
hard time understanding the thought
process behind that what part of of the
acts of terrorism that we're with
witnessing in the proxy wars that
they're fighting are they not
understanding Sean I can't explain it I
wish I could often I can articulate
someone's views even if they're
different from mine this one is
completely unexplainable to me think
about this today while while we've been
sitting here today in the United States
4 million barrels of Iranian crude oil
were sold in the open market generating
hundreds of millions of dollars for the
Iranian regime after they've killed 30
Americans I mean that's today forget
what they did last last week or 6 months
ago or a year ago this policy Still
Remains in place they have to get
serious about protecting America we we
now have two Wars that have been started
in the last two and a half years it
wasn't inevitable Sean this wasn't
something that had to be uh we need to
pray and work for peace but mostly the
United States needs to demonstrate its
resolved its strength and when we do we
can deter these folks from doing these
horrific things evil runs on the earth
Sean we know that it requires good
people to stand up and defend their own
sovereignty
what happens if Iran involves itself in
this conflict to me that would be a
moment where all bets are off and the
entire Middle East could be engulfed in
a full uh fledged War uh and what should
the response be of Israel and the US
last
question I'll give you three three
groups that should respond the United
States should do what it knows how to do
best and support actors in the region to
push back against Iran and frankly Sean
I'd argue Iran is our in this War uh
second Israel will do its part it'll
it'll continue to defend its own
sovereignty and then I'm convinced too
there'll be rockets and missiles falling
all across the Middle East I'm convinced
uh that all of the power that can be
brought to bear some of it sitting in
the Persian Gulf some of it sitting in
alud air force base uh American power
throughout the region will be used and
I'm convinced our Gulf era Partners will
see this threat from Iran for themselves
as well and collectively I am confident
we can make the cost on the ayatolla so
significant that his own people will
demand that they change their behavior
all right secretary Mike Pompeo thank
you sir for being with us we always
appreciate your time hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else